all right it is uh I would say it's
getting warm here in Boston but that's
not true today but it went through a
couple days ago as is often the case in
this part of the country and on my
Instagram account at David Pakman
I recently posted a picture of the
thermostat on my car showing a balmy 102
degrees Fahrenheit
and this is just this this is not good
weather for me I just don't do well in
this kind of extreme heat and
immediately after I posted this pad
people were saying well number one
people were saying David you know if you
lived in X other area then Y would be
the temperature I don't live in those
areas I live in Boston so I'm dealing
with the temperature in Boston and
number two I was criticized for people
saying that I was listening to fake news
because as you can see in this picture
CNN is the channel I was listening to on
my Sirius XM radio and I got a lot of
heat for for this picture where I
admitted to listening to CNN in the car
very very hot in Boston are you into or
not into the heat I'm not into the heat
oh there we go transition - I think that
was the problem again from being 50
degrees to 90 in a couple of days right
and even 102 according to some documents
that I provided to the Internet okay
also I took a picture of this really
great book I'm reading it is called
narco anomic by Tom Wainwright and a
couple people that saw this actually
said they're reading the book as well
excellent excellent non-fiction book
about all aspects of the drug world and
this includes the war on drugs this
includes the manufacture of cocaine the
manufacture of marijuana online sale of
drugs incarceration all sorts of stuff I
would anticipate Pat and I know that
you're going to make a note of this that
I might at some point recommend this
book on the Friday recommendation
segment and/or try to interview the
author Tom Wainwright really good new
nonfiction book would you also recommend
running a drug cartel from what I'm
reading in this book it seems like it's
really not a good idea if you value your
life all right let me put it that way
yeah narco dynamics Tom Wainwright
people liking that you can follow me on
instagram at david pakman nearly 20,000
other people
now follow me i dindt on instagram at
david pakman